ja wir leben in einem zeitalter in dem
unmögliches möglich wird der absolute
nullpunkt gelder geht nicht dachte man
unmöglichkeit - gerade in der physik ein
deutsches forschungsteam hat aber ein
atomares gas geschaffen das negative
calvin werte annehmen kann
wie soll das gehen und warum das ein
hinweis auf die mysteriöse dunkle
energie sein könnte das jetzt in klicks
um science-fiction und danke für diesen
spannenden themen vorschlag in den
messenger herzlich willkommen
ja und wie ihr über die messenger tender
gramm facebook whatsapp und instagram
mitmachen können dass er vater am ende
des videos
es ist eigentlich unumstößlich je
langsamer die chaotische bewegung der
teilchen ist desto niedriger ist die
temperatur bei minus 273 grad celsius
oder eben null kelvin verhalten sich
alle teilchen still und die unordnung
verschwindet nichts geht mehr der
absolute nullpunkt vielleicht habt ihr
im physikunterricht ja auch schon mal
was von der sogenannten boltzmann
verteilung gehört da geht es um die
verteilung der bewegungsenergie
verteilen einfaches beispiel wenn man
wasser energie zuführt erhitzte sich und
die wassermoleküle bewegen sich immer
schneller sie erhöhen also ihre
bewegungsenergie allerdings nur im
durchschnitt gesehen
denn tatsächlich ist es so dass die
einzelnen moleküle eine sehr
unterschiedliche energie aufweisen
manche sind sehr langsam
einige sind sehr schnell und es sind nur
wenige teilchen die sich sehr schnell
bewegen
denn diese energie zustand ist nicht so
wahrscheinlich wie ein zustand mit
niedriger energie ein forschungsteam von
max planck institut hat tatsächlich ein
gas realisiert bei dem diese verteilung
genau anders rum s und sich mit dieser
umkehrung auch das vorzeichen der
temperatur um kerth es wird negativ wir
haben nur wenige teilchen eine niedrige
energie viele weisen dagegen eine hohe
energie auf und so bedeutet das konkret
die teilchen haben eine negative
temperatur angenommen doch jetzt kommt
das paradoxe daran dass ich eben nicht
kälter als null kelvin sondern heißer
naja es ist echt absoluter wahnsinn dazu
einer der beteiligten forscher ulrich
schneider
die umgekehrte boltzmann verteilung ist
genau das was eine negative absolute
temperatur ausmacht und die haben wir
erreicht dass gas ist sogar heißer als
bei jeder beliebigen positiven
temperatur die temperatur skala hört bei
unendlich einfach noch nicht auf sondern
springt zu negativen werten leute da bin
ich jetzt auch absolut wirklich baff
unter null kelvin und trotzdem heiß und
extrem heißes gas hat eine temperatur
unter null kelvin was okay langsam was
bedeutet das jetzt genau oft lassen sich
solche energiezustände mit dem bild von
rollenden kugeln
einer landschaft veranschaulichen das
tal oder kleine mulden stehen für eine
niedrige potenzielle energie hügel oder
kleine erhebung für eine hohe
potenzielle energie
je höher die kinetische energie der
teilchen ist desto schneller bewegen
sich die kugeln wenn die temperatur
positiv ist dann ist die gesamte energie
der kugeln groß sie verteilen sich in
der landschaft auch auf die bereiche
hoher energie wenn man sie unendlich
hoch erhitzen könnte wären sie
unabhängig von ihrer potenziellen
energie an jedem ort anzutreffen und
zwar mit der gleichen wahrscheinlichkeit
wenn dann weiter energie zugeführt würde
und man die kugeln weiter aufheizen
würde wären sie vor allem bei den
energie zuständen mit hoher energie
anzutreffen sie werden dann noch heißer
als bei unendlicher temperatur dann wäre
die sogenannte boltzmann verteilung
umgekehrt und die temperatur kippt ins
negative paradox klingt das schon dass
eine negative absoluten temperatur
heißer ist als eine positive doch das
ergibt sich einfach aus der definition
der absoluten temperatur von natürlichen
systemen und wasser da ist das ganze
nicht möglich schließlich müsse das
system dafür unendlich viel energie
aufnehmen können was eben nicht möglich
ist denn nötig für solch eine umkehrung
der bordwand verteilung ist quasi eine
obere grenze für die energie wie eben
die spitze eines hügels das
forschungsteam des max-planck-instituts
für quantenphysik münchen hat sich genau
das zunutze gemacht in ihrem experiment
kühlten sie rund 100000 atome in einer
vakuumkammer ab und zwar auf eine
temperatur von wenigsten wenigen
milliardstel kelvin dann setzen sie
laserstrahlen ein um die atome thermisch
von der umwelt zu isolieren die atome
ordnen sie auf einem optischen gitter an
dass die laserstrahlen gebildet hatten
zwar können sich die atome von gitta zu
gitterplatz bewegen doch ist ihre
bewegungsenergie nach oben hin
beschränkt das forschungsteam setzt sich
jedoch nicht nur der bewegungsenergie
eine grenze nach oben sondern ihre
gesamten energie potenzielle und
wechselwirkung energie eingeschlossen
dann brachten sie die atome an ihre
obergrenze der gesamtenergie und damit
war die temperatur negativ weil jetzt
eben sich viel viel mehr teilchen eben
hat eine hohe energie- und damals mit
diese boltzmann verteilung umgekehrt
also - einige milliardstel kelvin war
das ganze jetzt kalt heiß naja ok das
tolle an der ganzen sache der zustand
der teilchen ist bei negativer
temperatur genauso stabil wie bei
positiver temperatur dazu simon braun
einer der beteiligten forscher haben die
kugeln aber eine negative temperatur
dann ist auch ihre bewegungsenergie
schon so groß dass sie nicht weiter
zunehmen kann daher können die kugeln
nicht hinunter rollen und bleiben auf
dem hügel liegen die energie schranke
macht das system also stabil und damit
sind wir wirklich in eine vollkommen
neue dimension vorgestoßen
jetzt sind wärme kraftmaschinen denkbar
die eine effizienz von mehr als 100
haben denn sie können nicht nur energie
aus einem heißen medium ziehen so wie
wir es bisher kennen sondern eben auch
aus einem kalten anders als bei
positiven temperaturen würde die
effizienz nicht gemindert werden nämlich
dadurch dass ich das kältere medium
aufheizt und so ein teil der energie des
heißen mediums wegnimmt aber auch für
die kosmologie ist das ein spannender
ansatz denn thermodynamischen diese
negative temperatur der sogenannten
dunklen energie zu er weiß man noch
nicht wirklich viel forschungsgruppen
gehen aber davon aus dass diese kraft
dafür verantwortlich ist dass sich der
kosmos immer weiter ausdehnt und das
obwohl er sich wegen der anziehenden
gravitation der materie im universum
eigentlich zusammen ziehen sollte die
ähnlichkeit zu dem münchner experiment
die atome des gases haben sich nicht wie
gewöhnlich abgestoßen sondern angezogen
sie üben also einen negativen druck aus
und wegen der negativen temperatur
kollabiert die atomwolke eben nicht
obwohl man es erwarten könnte wirklich
absolut irre ich bin gespannt ob es dazu
bald weitere erkenntnisse gibt denn
dieses gas wurde bereits 2013 entwickelt
danke dafür dass er das thema gefunden
hat und mir auch prozent vorgeschlagen
habe das werden wir eben absolut
durchgegangen ansonsten wenn ihr da
mitmachen wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp oder per
telegramm oder eher können wir auch bei
instagram und im facebook messenger
folgen dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor
allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
und garantiert und zu begrüßen gibt es
ein kleines goodie einfach hier drauf
trinken und natürlich nicht das abo mit
der
genau mit der glocke vergessen und hier
geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken riesen atom zum ersten mal
im weltall hergestellt ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran